Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Flanqueado por dos poderosas
naciones europeas, el Canal de la Mancha
ha sido uno de los pasajes marítimos
más importantes.
Sin embargo,
durante la mayor parte de su historia,
las costas rocosas del canal
y su clima tormentoso
hicieron peligroso cruzarlo.
Ingenieros de principios de 1800
propusieron numerosos planes
para atravesar la brecha de 33 km.
Sus diseños incluían islas artificiales
unidas por puentes,
tubos sumergidos suspendidos
desde plataformas flotantes,
y un pasaje submarino más de dos veces
la longitud de cualquier túnel existente.
A finales de siglo,
esta última propuesta había capturado
la imaginación europea.
La invención de la tuneladora
y el descubrimiento de una capa estable
de tiza marga debajo del fondo marino
hicieron más factible
este fantástico túnel.
Pero los obstáculos
más urgentes del proyecto.
fueron los que ningún ingeniero
pudo resolver.
En ese momento,
los británicos vieron su aislamiento
geográfico como ventaja estratégica
y temores sobre una invasión francesa
hicieron cerrar los planes para el túnel.
El surgimiento de la guerra aérea volvió
estas preocupaciones obsoletas,
pero nuevas preocupaciones económicas
surgieron para reemplazarlas.
Finalmente, 100 años después
de la excavación inicial
los dos países llegaron a un acuerdo:
el túnel se haría
con financiación privada.
En 1985, un grupo
de empresas francesas y británicas
invirtieron el equivalente moderno
de 14 mil millones de libras,
haciendo que el túnel fuera el proyecto de
infraestructura más caro hasta la fecha.
El diseño pedía tres túneles separados,
uno para trenes a Francia,
uno para trenes a Inglaterra,
y un túnel de servicio entre ellos.
Junto a cámaras cruzadas, conductos
de emergencia y conductos de aire,
esto ascendió a más de 200 km de túneles.
En 1988, los trabajadores comenzaron
a excavar por ambos lados,
planeando reunirse en el medio.
Estudios iniciales de la costa francesa
revelaron que el sitio
estaba lleno de fallas.
Estas pequeñas grietas
dejan que se filtrara el agua en la roca,
así que los ingenieros tuvieron que
desarrollar tuneladoras impermeables.
Los británicos anticiparon
condiciones más secas,
y siguieron adelante
con perforadores regulares.
Pero solo unos meses en el trabajo, entró
agua a través de fisuras no detectadas.
Para perforar esta tiza húmeda,
los británicos tuvieron que usar lechada
para sellar las grietas
creada en la raíz del barrenador,
e incluso trabajar por delante
del barrenador principal
para reforzar la tiza
a punto de ser perforada.
Con estos obstáculos superados,
ambos equipos comenzaron
a perforar a toda velocidad.
Tuneladoras de hasta 1300 toneladas
perforaban a casi 3.5 m por hora.
Mientras cavaban,
instalaron anillos de revestimiento
para estabilizar el túnel detrás de ellos,
abriendo paso a los vagones de apoyo
que seguían cada máquina.
Incluso a toda velocidad,
el trabajo tuvo que proceder con cuidado.
La capa de tiza seguía un camino sinuoso
entre roca inestable y arcilla,
punzada por más de 100 agujeros perforados
por agrimensores anteriores.
Además, ambos equipos tenían que
verificar constantemente sus coordenadas
para asegurarse de que estaban
en camino de encontrarse
en un margen de 2 cm el uno del otro.
Para mantener esta delicada trayectoria,
los barrenadores empleaban
sistemas de posicionamiento satelital,
así como paleontólogos
que usaban fósiles excavados
para confirmar que estaban
a la profundidad correcta.
Durante la construcción, el proyecto
empleó a más de 13 000 personas
y costó la vida de diez trabajadores.
Pero después de dos años y medio
de tunelización,
los dos lados finalmente
hicieron contacto.
El trabajador británico Graham Fagg
surgió en el lado francés,
convirtiéndose en el primer humano
en cruzar el canal por tierra
desde la Edad de Hielo.
Aún quedaba trabajo por hacer.
desde la instalación de cámaras cruzadas
y estaciones de bombeo,
a poner más de 160 km de pistas,
cables y sensores.
Pero el 6 de mayo de 1994,
una ceremonia de apertura.
marcó la finalización del túnel.
Comenzó el servicio público completo
16 meses después con trenes
para pasajeros y transbordadores
ferroviarios para automóviles y camiones.
Hoy, el túnel del canal sirve a más de
20 millones de pasajeros al año,
transporta pasajeros a través del canal
en solo 35 minutos.
Desafortunadamente,
no todos tienen el privilegio
de hacer este viaje legalmente.
Miles de refugiados lo han intentado
para entrar a Gran Bretaña
a través del túnel
en intentos a veces fatales.
Estas tragedias han transformado
la entrada sur del túnel
en un sitio de continuo conflicto.
Con suerte, la historia de la estructura.
puede servir como recordatorio
de que la humanidad está en su
mejor momento al derribar barreras.